I'm actually surprised that this next story
continued to blow up the way that it has.
Donald Trump is now demanding that a pollster
apologize to him and cease and desist because
a poll said that he's losing to Joe Biden
and he doesn't believe that he's losing to
Joe Biden, I guess.
So this Monday, this poll was published from
CNN.
Remember that the CNN poll, CNN polling, first
of all, is not the same as CNN.
Much the same way that Fox News.
Paul polling is not the same as Fox News broadcast.
The CNN SSR s poll said that Joe Biden is
ahead of Donald Trump nationally by 14 points.
This is a huge margin, 55 to 41.
We don't know if this margin will hold.
This is just one poll.
Trump was furious.
So first, Trump started tweeting that the
poll is fake.
On Tuesday, Donald Trump hired some other
pollster to write a letter saying how bad
the CNN poll is, including by lying about
the CNN poll.
So, for example, the pollster that Trump hired
said that this was a poll of all adults rather
than people who are going to vote.
If you look at the methodology of the poll,
you see very clearly it is a poll of registered
voters.
Now, you can make the case that a poll of
likely voters would be more accurate.
But the poll is a poll of registered voters.
This McGlaughlin guy falsely claimed it's
a poll of all adults.
So the debunked letter was riddled with lies.
Then Donald Trump started with the legal threats,
triggered Trump demanding that the poll be
retracted and that CNN apologized to him.
Trump says the poll has to be retracted because
he feels it's not fair or accurate or well
done and that it seeks to suppress the vote
for Donald Trump.
Now I look back.
Let me get to that limit to get to the suppression
a little bit later.
The letter that was written to CNN accuses
the network of trying to mislead voters through
a biased questionnaire and skewed sampling,
claiming they released a, quote, phony poll
to cause voter suppression.
Trump's cease and desist letter, which threatens
legal action, is something I am not aware
of ever happening in this country.
The president of the United States threatening
legal action over poll results that he doesn't
doesn't like or disagrees with is completely
outrageous.
This is the type of thing you might imagine
happens in North Korea, Venezuela, China,
Russia, places like that.
You don't imagine that in the U.S., presidents
threaten pollsters over scientific polls.
Now, it's important for you to know that this
poll is not that much of an outlier in terms
of Trump vs. Biden.
So for sure, a 14 point lead for Biden is
the biggest that we've seen in any poll so
far.
But if you look at other recent polls, Joe
Biden is ahead of Trump by 10 in a few polls,
by eleven in one poll.
So 14 is high, but it's not like it's completely
crazy where every other poll says it's a tie
or Trump is winning.
And CNN drops a poll that says Biden plus
14.
When you look at May and June, Biden's winning
every poll and it's a matter of by how much.
The point is demanding a retraction and an
apology is bizarre.
It shows no one again.
Trump's a trigonal snowflake.
He is.
He is so thin skinned.
Number two, Trump is insecure about what's
going on with polling.
And let me dig into that a little bit.
And this is what I was going to get to earlier.
Trump claims that a poll showing Biden is
winning will suppress or is trying to suppress
Trump voters from turning out.
That only would be true if your voters don't
really like you that much, because in general,
if I find out that the candidate I support
is down.
If anything, that makes me more likely to
go out and vote.
In other words, here in Massachusetts, I'm
voting no matter what.
In Massachusetts, Biden is likely to win.
If the polling says Biden is up 30 in Massachusetts,
I'm going to vote because I vote no matter
what.
But I might be less urgently voting than if
a poll came out and said, Massachusetts in
play.
Trump only down two in Massachusetts.
Then I'm I mean, I'm voting either way, but
I'm even more definitely going to get out
and vote, if that makes sense.
So Trump's analysis that saying Biden is winning
is a way to try to suppress Trump supporters.
Voting, they must be very unenthusiastic supporters
if they would be moved not to vote because
their guy is losing in a lot of parts of the
country with a lot of types of people, if
you see your candidate is down or that it's
close.
You're damn sure going to get out to vote.
So that that's that up.
Now, in terms of CNN's response.
They said they stand by the poll as expected
that they did the poll.
They're a good pollster.
That's it.
Imagine ESPN being told, hey, you've got to
report a different final score.
All right.
Imagine that the Boston Celtics defeat the
Washington.
What are they called now?
The Washington can forget what is.
What is the name of the Washington?
It used to be the Bulls.
The Wizards.
I'm sorry.
Imagine the Celltex defeat the WIST Wizards
by 10 and Wizards management calls ESPN and
says, could you report a different score,
please?
Because we just don't really agree that that's
the score.
How does a Trump voter see this and see Trump
as the alpha male that he claims to be?
He doesn't like a poll, so he cries and says
everyone's being unfair to him and sends a
legal threat to cowardly move.
Go win an election if you're sure that the
poll is fake and then we'll have all the proof
we need, assuming it's a fair election, which
Donald Trump is trying to ensure it will not
be.
To be honest, I feel like the presidency of
Trump is far more fake than this CNN poll.
But ultimately, we will know in five months,
four and a half months at this point, five
months, four months, three weeks, whether
these polls reflect a rising tide against
Donald Trump or whether he's going to be able
to pull it off.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman.
Many exciting things
are happening.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman
dot com.